I was taught to cook buying very well
with respect Italian chef that's total
[ __ ] because there was nothing
Italian there nothing anywhere Alex
tells me this well-respected chef is
still in the area maybe he can shed some
light on the source of Alex's
inspiration be Mario the famous chef
yeah you taught Alex everything he knew
is that right yeah and did you introduce
him to bechamel and Demi glass and
masala yeah there was you what I'm the
responsible one or something go wrong
[ __ ] you now forever I want me to start
ah it turns out Alec spent his formative
years with Italian born Mario known
locally as Hoffa jizz king of the
chatter Ria's and obviously went very
well because you know you're a taxi
driver
no it's a penis tidge where was for that
by the kitchen brilliant if it doesn't
work out for Alex I suppose they can
come and bring him to the rank yeah cuz
he's food [ __ ] rank yeah yeah see
place allows his rivals well he's a
lousy driver as well [ __ ] now I'll let
you get back to your rank
thank you very soft those hands they're
like babies bottoms get back in the
kitchen yeah Jam area
it seems the extent of Alex's knowledge
of authentic Italian cuisine stretches
no further than Luton Alex needs to bite
the bullet and relaunch the restaurant
with a fresh identity of his own but a
new image cost money and Isis at the end
of his tether financially how'd you pay
yourself I haven't paid myself away for
four months bloody hell
I mean is your business really on the
line with going bust oh absolutely
is very much down the line cuz I'll lose
everything the house everything because
all it's all tied up in business so if
it all goes wrong I walk away with
absolutely nothing
Alex's past seems full of bad financial
decisions after just two weeks of
running Lanterna success went to his
head and instead of getting his cooker
fixed he spent forty six thousand pounds
on a new car
with no spare cash Alex can't afford to
turn the business around can you [ __ ]
slow down a bit please don't you see
why an earth did you buy it truthfully I
love cars I'm trying to say do you think
you've got your priorities right look
down at the number plate do you have a
small dick that you got to open anything
you don't need a car for transport to
get to work
no you live above the restaurant new
commitments yeah big responsibility
absolutely [ __ ] big responsibility
then you go splash out of the [ __ ]
car yeah so we got a recuperating money
back to get back into the business to
keep the business open I'm saying so
we've got a something I mean if you had
the choice of keeping the car and
closing the business cuz that's what's
gonna happen shortly use the car key the
business
at last he's got his priorities right
and with the car up for sale on the
Internet
I've got him a good deal on a new cooker
need to get 38 for it to clear the
finance [ __ ] maybe I can ring around
until we get rid of that number plate
please do now let's think you're a
[ __ ] grade a class a chef hi Anthony
I need some help please everyone knows I
have a lot of respect for TV chef Anton
roll Thompson not your cup of tea I
didn't think it would be you know that
and we know you're not in need of a
penis extension exactly that you're not
interested John Christopher Lee I'll
give you a call
hey JC please I'm trying to so no no no
miss I'm trying to sell it I'm listening
to the memory ask what's wrong with the
primer play then with the can the number
plate up for sale we can move forward
it's time to get Alex to do something he
clearly hasn't done for a very long time
I want him to start cooking
you